I think I think men and women cannot be
equal I think that's where we go wrong
and why why do you think that because
men are superior you think that Menace
Superior to women yes name one thing
women are better at than men all hell
breaks loose yeah I think the natural
order of thing is God
men women I think women are below men
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series where I take women that
have been on the show and I show them
mgtow red pill and just other
conservative content welcome to the show
introduce yourself to the people hello
I'm Leila Lazelle I'm 25 and I'm a
content creator you do very fun Street
interviews right yeah yeah I do I love
that and you were you were born and
raised in London uh no so I'm actually
from York originally which is Northern
okay so today I'm gonna show you a mgtow
video
do you know what mgtow is no I've got no
idea so mgtow is men that go their own
way oh wow it's like kind of like in
cells I don't think so oh okay I don't
think so I mean some call them in cells
right I call them men that are very
logical oh really yes yes but pull up
the video so this is an introduction to
mgtow this is by Sandman
hi everyone Sandman here I'm getting a
number of people asking me to do an
introduction video for mgtow so here it
is I'm going to cover 25 of the most
important video topics that I've covered
since I've started my channel and the
first thing to remember about mgtow is
that a man that has taken the
metaphorical red pill is a man that has
learned the ugly truth about female
nature
women are made out to be harmless
Beautiful Creatures but the truth is
many women today will rip out your heart
and testicles through your wallet and
move on to their next victim with
absolutely no second thoughts and they
often have no guilt or remorse in the
process
so taking the red pill is making
yourself aware of how women operate and
you stop being naive about it with
regards to becoming a mgtow there are
four or five different levels to mgtow
the first level is the purple pill man
this is the man that's aware that women
use the government the courts and men's
desires to reproduce to take advantage
of men but the purple pill man believes
that the risks of a relationship in
marriage are often worth the potential
punishment
a level 2 mgtow believes in dating and
short-term relationships but not
marriage long-term relationships or
cohabitation with women
what do you think of that men that walk
away from Marriage men that walk away
from Marriage yeah
um but what's the reason what's the
reason that they've walked away just in
general the reasoning is the court
system is not fair to men right so you
mean men that never want to get married
in the correct place
um I guess it's a very like cynical way
to view life like you know not wanting
to open your heart up to someone in that
way and feeling like you you have to
kind of sacrifice that because you know
these bad things might happen
um because I feel like that kind of
happens in the minority of cases rather
than the majority so what what percent
of marriages end in divorce well is it
like 50 yeah yeah okay okay so it's like
harder but I don't know that the cases
where they walk away with the children
and take everything that might not be
the case but so men only get 50 like men
only get primary custody 10 of the time
yeah so it's actually if they get
divorced it's the majority right and
then what about um like Financial
um what do you mean like do they get
taken like advantage of financially in
that kind of way well the numbers I
can't off the top of my head I don't
know but I think men get like to the
point where they they think it was
malicious it's like 15 to 20 percent of
divorces right oh wow that is quite High
then it's very high and I think that's
under report like you'd be I started
asking Uber drivers yeah it's like crazy
how many Uber drivers I've like not I
just would ask them like how they
started ubering whatever yeah and I was
like shocked by how many were just
screwed over in divorced really yeah no
and I do think that that's really sad
yeah it's really sad for the guys and
then so I can kind of understand why
they would be skept about it but it
makes me sad that they would live their
life which is why we should ban divorce
wow that is quite the statement yes yes
yeah because I think that like what we
have now it's not marriage anymore yeah
I think that like you saw me on Pierce
Morgan yeah so like I don't think like
what we have today is like real marriage
yeah and I think like if you believe in
divorce you just shouldn't get married
yeah no I but the thing is does anyone
get married with the intention of
getting divorced yes
right okay well yeah I agree with you
then that people shouldn't get married
with the intention of getting divorced I
mean I believe that it should be forever
yeah 100 I would never marry someone if
I didn't think that it was going to be
forever but then at the same time you
never know how things are going to go
yeah but that's why I think we can have
a couple exceptions yeah okay I mean
with like abusive relationships I think
is it like 25 of American divorces are
because of it was an abusive well but
the problem is they they
ruin like those stats aren't real and
I'll tell you why because what happens
is they do it in family court and not
criminal court right and so in family
court you don't need evidence to do it
right and I've even had like women like
I've seen because I'm doing a
documentary on this stuff so I've
interviewed men where they bring in the
court documents and the women are
literally plotting to get the guy to hit
them so they can go to court and claim
abuse and there's only criminal so when
you go to Criminal Court you there you
get a jury it's like innocent until
proven guilty but the way Family Court
works it's basically guilty until proven
innocent right so like and so we want to
look at what percent of cases are
actually abusive it's like I think 10 of
all the women that say they were abused
filed an actual police report right but
then do you think that maybe some of
them don't file the police report
because of the way that it can be
handled sometimes as we know with like
it's only is it only like one percent
actually get prosecuted no I think that
women do that because they want to get
the kids right and they think they lie
but do you think that that's the case in
the majority of those cases yes right
yes that is messed up yes the truth yes
I I think
um women are very spiteful yeah and I
think we are the worst version of
ourselves during a breakup right I I
would agree and I think we can all think
of a time and a breakup where we have
done something yes get gone crazy right
and done something that maybe like was
out of character for us right but the
way we have it now the government is
legally allowing us to ruin the person
you hate more than anyone on the
planet's life and I in the same way I
think if we got men super angry to the
point they want to kill somebody right
when they're like in a fight at a bar
yeah and the government came in and said
here's a gun yeah you can legally kill
him with no consequence I think a lot of
men would do it yeah the same way I
think a lot of women would women do do
it because I think women that actually
care about the safety of the kids would
have gone to the police right yeah
yeah that's a really good point actually
and they wouldn't want him to keep it
like women that care about women
wouldn't want them to keep abusing women
no 100 so it's like why are you going to
family court and saying he was abusive
if you didn't go to the police because I
would understand being too afraid to do
anything yeah if they're just going to
one and not the other then and the
problem is in in Family Court they've
expanded the definition of abuse so what
the feminists do is they come into these
systems and they change the definition
of words right and they've done this
with like what is sexual assault
when someone
uh does something without consent like
sexual right what is consent how do you
how do you know what's consenting
um I feel like it's
it's um either them verbally giving
concern or it can be more of like a body
language right but do you see how
subjective that is yeah I feel like it's
it kind of is obvious as well like have
you ever heard a girl say like stop stop
like in a flirty way yeah definitely
okay do you see how that's confusing to
men but I feel like that wouldn't be
confusing because you would know surely
well that's what you would think but she
can still go to court and say I said
stop okay you see so yeah the problem is
before it was very clear it was like
forced yeah it was um I forgot the
forest Carnage six yeah four sex
basically yeah now it sucks without
consent right so that makes that gives
the women a lot of power to say oh I I
was consenting then not consenting that
yeah I mean isn't the full succusation
rate only like two percent though no no
I think it's a lot higher because well I
mean I guess you it technically wouldn't
even be a false accusation because it
would fall under the law yeah I think
the way that law they have changed the
law is discriminatory towards men right
because it's a it's illegal for a man to
take off a condom during sex and not
tell you that's yeah but women lie about
birth control all the time yeah there's
no and so what they've done in family
court it's different though because
obviously if they take the condom off
that could give you an STD obviously
birth control I wonder if you're saying
that it's right well I think it's
actually worse because uh you know STDs
I'd imagine I don't know but most are
curable nowadays but a kid that's like
18 that's 18 years that's really you
know and so
um what they did with abuse was they
expanded the definition right so they
changed the definitely I don't know what
the definition used to be exactly but
I'm imagining it's something like like
hitting her something like that now they
have coercive control right they have
Financial abuse they have
um like all of these words they add in
that are very subjective and to confuse
people and the problem is when we make
things subjective it gives the women the
power right okay so that's why I think
they're Liars wow that's that's a lot to
take in yeah yeah even um and it's
really they they all the feminists like
they I they know what they're doing the
women writing these laws because at the
thing is like I even here at women's
shelters they tell women what to say in
court so there's a whole system where
like the women's shelters have all these
feminists in them that have all been
trained by the same like Doctrine
basically and it's in the schools too
it's all same same people and so they go
the women go to the women's shelters and
they have a whole story line for you for
what you should say about your husband
so if he's if he's Nigerian they'll give
you one story oh they're controlling
there they're this if he's from India
they'll give you another oh is this
really true yes I've seen court
documents of uh I mean the the women's
shelter is hearsay I'll say that's just
based on you know you meet 10 people
with the same story yeah you start to
think okay maybe there's something so
they do this so that they can get
custody of the children correct because
the women's shelters it's all like a
money scheme basically the women's
shelters like are paid by getting the
women the kids yeah so they have a
monetary incentive to go to court and
help them win so they get more women
they're paid my mind so should it not be
fair so like the kid goes to you know
whoever is the best parent or like 55 so
what yeah why aren't feminists that say
they're feminists why don't they want 50
50 custody off the bat and the funny
like as a feminist though that's what I
would want you you would think right but
but I'm telling you there's no you don't
you see a [__] walk but I don't see uh
give men their kids walk but I feel like
feminists do care about I mean me anyway
I care about those kind of issues as
well so why aren't you speaking about
them then well I'm speaking about them
right now
so I'll do did you ever hear the stat
that men only get custody of their kid
10 of the time I think maybe I've heard
something similar I don't know if I knew
that it was that low yeah and I do think
that that is really unfair and I feel
like it should be more easy and but my
thing is if feminists really cared about
about it we would see movements on their
side and I wish that there was like me
as a feminist I would love to see a
movement about that as well you could
start maybe I should yeah
but this is the problem you're gonna
face is all of the feminists are paid
off of this system right all of these
systems like there's money going in I
feel like they're not real feminists
then in my opinion no I think they're
exactly the real feminist because I'm
telling you I that book over there that
that's one of my books yeah it goes
through like all of the ways like
feminists have come in and and changed
the definition of laws and it gives
women power but then to me that's not
that's not a real feminist well the
question is like what's it what's a real
feminist yeah so I guess somebody that
does believe in equality but for both
sides and about choice and it's more I
guess obviously men and women are
different but I believe that we should
be treated in a way that's fair you know
we're taking into account our
differences as well what is fair
um can you give me like an example no
like what what is what is the fairness
that they're looking for well I just I
guess so that you know we're on an equal
playing field okay how do we how do we
get on an equal playing field how do we
get on an equal playing field I honestly
don't know like I feel like you know
maybe certain laws need to change maybe
the way that people of you need to
change like obviously
um with this example you know with like
men only getting custody 10 of the time
maybe it is a case of going back in and
rewriting the wording of these um laws
to make it more fair so yes but what's
what have feminists done what have what
have they done yes what do you mean what
have they been I'm saying the feminists
have changed the laws but is it
feminists that have done that is that
real feminists that believe in equality
yes I would say yes yes I could pull up
their names you know what's so funny
about what she's saying like I
understand where she's coming from but
it's not her fault it's like it's it's
that's how propaganda Works in it yeah
so for example the Nazis that fought in
the world war
if you were to interview all of them
they actually thought they were fighting
for a good cause
yeah but the real Nazis that were
pushing it they had their nefarious
agenda in it so it's kind of like the
same thing she thinks she's the real
feminist but you're what what you think
is feminism is what has been put in your
head to kind of distract you from what
is actually going on yeah I understand
what you're saying and I think there's
obviously bad and good in everything
uh say that I agree
but my version of feminism I guess is
that it's about equality I think I think
men and women cannot be equal I think
that's where we go wrong and why why do
you think that because men are superior
you think that men are superior to women
yes name one thing women are better at
than men
um taking care of children they're more
likely to kill infants right yeah I
guess and single mother homes have way
worse numbers than single father Homes
single father home stats are better than
women
um okay what about being nurses I swear
like isn't it like 90 of nurses are
female how what's what's higher a nurse
or a doctor a doctor okay who's more
doctors I don't know men men okay I
think women actually are um because I
think even if it's higher it doesn't
mean that it's less important but but it
yes it does yes it does do you think but
see this is what feminism does it says
even if you're better we're still equal
right but a brain surgeon is better than
a nurse yeah like objectively but I
still think that it can be important as
well we're not saying not important but
I'm saying what are women better at
um
I feel like it's hard because it's like
such a it's okay it's okay you've never
thought about it yeah because I use I
I've genuinely for months been trying to
find something I mean I mean I've never
I've never thought about what men are
better but I can name a few
so wait what would you say that men are
better at then everything but like what
give give me an example
um building the buildings Paving the
road oh I know I've got a good one right
so I feel like where men do all the
infrastructure right yes women we kind
of are the biggest consumers so I feel
like we influence culture more so maybe
that's our strength and how and did we
do and what has the world come to yes
we're gonna say oh you're gonna say oh
great it's terrible so it's our fault
yes yes I think I think the culture
right now is worse than a hundred years
ago I would say because I think family
is more important than individuality
yeah and I think right now it's all
about like me yeah and I think that's
what women have done to the culture I
think when women are Guided by men we
can be great wives and mothers and be
very great for the culture yeah but
without men all hell breaks loose yeah I
think the natural order of thing is God
men women I think women are below men
trying to think of one thing yeah and I
and I don't I don't mean I can't think
of one thing that women are better at no
and it's not to say that women are bad
at things I can think of great women
smart women great wives and mothers but
the point is that men will always figure
out a way to do things better literally
the only thing women are better at men
are are things that men can't do so for
instance giving birth
but you see even that which women are
supposed to be so good at they are
really doing a terrible job at doing
that because the birth rate is dropping
yeah it's like below replacement yeah
so so my my the whole premise of
feminism is that we're equal and my my
thing is we cannot be equal because men
pay the majority of the taxes they do
all of the hard jobs in society they
they make the majority they pay the
majority the taxes they do the majority
of the hard jobs they run the biggest
Employers in the United States or UK
so
I think it makes sense that they get
more of a say right yeah that that's my
thing and I think that like the premise
that men and women are equal is lying to
women because we are not equal they do
everything better objectively right I
was thinking cooking and then I looked
up the top Michelin chefs I was like
damn it no no another one and I I
couldn't I for months have been trying
to find one thing I I've heard that
women can detect facial
um
like like um emotion better than men
Yeah Yeah from a cycle yeah from a
psychological perspective there must be
loads of things like that yes and so you
would think we would Dominate and make
money off of that but we don't the top
salesmen are still men
what am I supposed to like maybe we
should just all go home and be
stay-at-home wives then after all well
you know Society works better that way
I'm not saying everyone should do that
there's always been high IQ women in
history that have been very influential
and have done really great things I
guess it's individualistic as well
obviously you can make generalizations
so generally okay maybe men are better
at all of these other things but there's
got it there's got to be individual
women there have been individual women
that are high IQ in history that men
have even traveled for miles to like get
wisdom from or whatever because they're
probably she's probably talking rubbish
anyway but but but there's always been
high IQ women in history but the thing
is most of the women making a lot of
money monetize Beauty in some way me and
you are an entertainment that's
monetizing Beauty it's a lot easier for
me or you to blow up than it is for a
guy 100 and I know this because I've
managed men and women gosh women are so
much easier
so it's like um
the industries that we dominate and
aren't based on competence it's based
off of beauty right
that is a hard pill to swallow isn't it
I don't say this like because do you
think that that's because of the way
that Society is and because it is kind
of a man's world do you think that
that's the reason I think if women could
make it a woman's world we would have
built a world right so you think that we
would have done that by now correct I
think we've had thousands of years to
build a world and we couldn't do it I
mean thousands of years where a lot of
people were oppressed like a lot of
women were a lot more oppressed it was a
lot more difficult well how do you
oppress someone
um I don't know you have to build a
society first right which I I don't
think women were oppressed I think most
women had more rights than most men do
you think yeah therefore throughout
history like ancient history oh yeah oh
yeah like men were sacrificed to the
gods
yeah like men have been yeah so have
women though yeah but men men are the
ones in war you have to go but then a
lot of women will get married off at
like the age of 12 like in ancient
Athens for example and then you know to
like an older older guy and obviously
that still happens in today's world I
think that was because the the life
expectancy was lower though wasn't what
about the guys being old and then being
married women like older men I'm not
saying oh I'm not saying 12 12 is a bit
young but I think a lot of times we
judge a different time period by what
was normal at the time yeah I think I
think people will judge our time period
and say that we were oppressing men
right I think they're good yes I think
they're gonna look back back at this
time period and think that the way that
men are treated in the court system the
way that men are treated like the power
that women have is oppressive towards
men I think I agree yes but I also agree
that women are still oppressed equally
as much I would like to one give me one
way so for example like the violence
against women like you know a lot
there's surely a lot more women murdered
by men no and there's more men are men
are more likely to be victims of a
violence it's okay they trick you oh
they put you in school and they say
here's all this stuff that's not true
it's obviously as a woman I don't know
about you but I don't feel safe walking
home at night like do you uh King do you
feel safe walking home at night
really I think that me and you are safer
than King do you think yeah because
you're a pretty girl
does something maybe make me more of a
Target yeah potentially but I think men
are more willing to help you than
another I just saw a video of a guy
getting stabbed on a train in front of
everybody no yeah I just saw a guy
getting shot like in New York just on
there correct I think men are more
likely to step in if it's a woman victim
than if it's a man but then what if
there's no one around though and it is
just the individual well you know then
it's still even with a man that he's
still the individual team yeah yeah but
but I think there's systems in place
that protect us yeah that men still have
to do right so how are we able to like
if I'm in my apartment well I mean now
they have women police officers but it's
still a small percentage so if I'm at
home alone I still have to call a man
yeah right and so if anything we should
be saying thank you men no yeah I feel
like we should definitely be grateful
like 100 of course and I'm not saying
that men and women are exactly the same
but I do feel feel like it's not just
men that have the the bad things
happening to them I feel like it is also
women yeah maybe just in different ways
I just want to think of a way that is
like worse for women
um I mean I guess obviously what I
mentioned before isn't it only like one
percent of great
cases like actually go to court and a
prosecute so it's interesting because me
and you are going to look at this
differently yeah I'm gonna say one
percent of grape cases had enough
evidence yeah and I
think that it's still we have to go off
the premise that they're innocent until
they're guilty of course so I don't
think we can equate in say an accusation
is a crime but at the same time I mean I
don't know about you but I don't think I
have like many friends that haven't
experienced some kind of essay yeah so I
think it's like very common obviously I
know you say innocent until proven
guilty yeah
um so it's difficult you know I can't
say that that's 100 true but the amount
of women that I know that have had
something like that happen to them what
are they what did they have happen essay
or like what like I have quite a lot
quite a few have been like you know the
date grape drug that that has happened
to a few um how do they know they just
didn't get too drunk how do they how are
they sure it was a date great uh I I
think you can tell can't you like you
know if you know if you've been drunk
however many times you know the
difference between that and then
completely so so I'm not saying that it
didn't happen yeah but what I'm saying
is this story like typically when I hear
these stories I don't hear a man took me
off the side of the road and raped me
but a lot of the time it happens from
like the boyfriend or someone close to
them as well I I think that's a way that
feminists have have convinced women that
were like oppressed right is is I like
because they'll say you were graped by a
boyfriend and it's just like it it it's
too subjective right yeah where it's
like what's consent what's not consent I
mean obviously until was it like the 70s
or something it was still legal for men
to like
their wife wasn't it well it's like I
guess since that laws come in then
that's when it opens up well I think the
problem is that gives the woman too much
power because essentially when you're
getting married that it really should be
lifelong consent yeah like I will have
sex with you forever yeah I mean for me
personally I don't have a problem with
that correct husband
he can get it right oh he can get it
absolutely he's gonna he's gonna pull
this clip someday and say see you but
but but the problem is that immediately
gives women that when we start like
believing women that are saying the
stuff it gives the women all the power
yeah because now she can go get a DNA
test and say he did it again we are the
worst versions of ourselves during a
breakup yeah so I'm not saying it
doesn't happen but I don't think it's as
common as feminists are saying and I
think a lot of women lie about it right
because I never if it's so common a man
or these like evil people I just don't
know why there's not more stories of
being like pulled off the side of the
road yeah it's always like it was a
boyfriend it was I was like I was date
graped when you know you start to get
the other side of the story and I just
think I have a hard time believing it
till I get both sides yeah no I
understand your perspective I think I
just I've heard too many experiences for
me to agree with that I have a
controversial take on this whole grip
thing I think
so a lot of feminists like to argue from
both sides of their mouth so they would
say
um
yeah um consent and all of this and that
and then they will try to make it like
okay
everything is the man's fault but then
they also remove you and remove the
possibility of asking what the woman was
doing why was she in that situation so
now you are not allowed to ask all of
that right because then it seems like
victim blaming but the reality is
knowing why she was in that situation
paint a fuller picture of why she was
gripped but then they take out that
whole path essentially making it that
there is no way on Earth it can be a
woman's fault it has to be the master
then it wasn't that there was a case
recently where a woman's underwear was
shown in court for example to prove that
like oh you know maybe she was asking
for it so I feel like that stuff still
does get brought up in the courtroom
um yeah but do you still take that into
consideration that you go as far as to
shame the victim that's for that's when
lawyers are trying to get their job done
in reality it doesn't go like that but
when you're trying to get to the truth
you have to ask questions yeah you do
have to ask the difficult questions of
course like I understand that I think
there is a difference though between
like holding someone's underwear open
court and shaming them for it as well
though
I don't know what what were they doing
so they um so there was a woman that had
been great and they held up her
underwear that she was wearing like a
thong and it was red and they tried to
use that to say that she was consenting
basically do you think women ever wear
red thongs to have sex
um yes but also I wouldn't say that
that's that it equates to concern I I
don't think it equates to it but could
it be evidence no I don't think it could
I I could see where the you know so you
could see where that was if she was in
lingerie you wouldn't think she might
have been planning on having sex but
then you can you know withdraw consent
at any time so you could turn up in the
laundry you could even be fully naked
and ready to go and then you can change
I think this is very confusing to men
you can you certainly can but I could
see where a guy would be confused so
he's like okay wait you're butt naked in
my bed yeah you and women also play say
no which we said earlier women do that
so now we're so
they want to be able to play their games
and still play victim afterwards
feminine nature you want to put yourself
in a dangerous situation and then have
someone save you and if someone doesn't
save you then you should you should
still also just to clarify no in that
situation I'm fully consenting and I
feel like it's about body language
though and it's about judging the
situation right but do you see how it
can be very confusing to a guy yes I
understand if the guy just doesn't
understand women I guess I feel like a
guy that understands women
so she gets into she gets naked in bed
yeah she play tells him no yeah and she
can withdraw consent
and now he's supposed to know she
doesn't want him yeah I understand how
that could be confusing yeah actually I
don't think majority of the cases is a
man that doesn't understand women I
actually think majority of the kisses
Amanda understands the game very well
but what happens is
they have their phone how many let me
ask you a question what percentage of
women do you think regret having sex
later oh a lot exactly so if she's
giving consent now and then later she
regrets it and then she she goes to the
court and says well she never gave
consent how is the man meant to prove
that he saw the body language I just
think surely if they regretted it they
wouldn't want to make a massive case out
of it they would probably just never
want to speak about it again or pretend
that it didn't happen I I think like I
have friends right maybe let me think of
a specific friend that's regretted
sleeping with with a guy she would just
want to pretend that that didn't happen
she would never want to go and make a
big deal out of it she has a lot of
people talking in her ears
right that can convince her that she was
gripped that's what usually happens she
she really doesn't want to come out with
the story but then she tells this friend
and the friends like oh my God that he
he graped you and then she tells the
next one oh my God but it's such a
traumatic experience to go through all
of the exams you know they have to do
like an internal exam to go through all
the women and women love their trauma
but to to have to go through all of that
though I don't think anyone would choose
to do that
and let's say like you know we're really
sure they've been proven that there have
been tons of women that have absolutely
chosen to go through that and been lying
I mean yeah I guess with like the full
formations I feel like surely the
majority of women wouldn't I think I
think I think if that was true false
accusations wouldn't be so common but
because if I ask if I ask okay okay so
these are two random men yeah do you
know anybody that's been falsely accused
raise both of them yeah easy do you know
more than one guy
three guys
three you three yeah no even I know one
like even you know even I know one yeah
okay so but I feel like the amount of
women I know that have been essayed is
like way way more okay but then
someone's lying right because if we're
hearing all the men that have been
falsely accused and all the women saying
they've been graped someone's lying but
I feel like it's a heart a far higher
number of people that have been
than it is people that I think I think
if that was true they would go to the
police
because I don't believe well I just I
just I think if women if women really
cared about women yeah and they would
make sure that grapes get locked up yeah
I just so either they don't so either I
don't think it's complicated at all but
yeah only one percent get prosecuted
they might be like
going through all of this it's like
traumatic to have to go through police
interviews and all of the exams like
that trauma this points back to what
we're trying to preach to women
you say what's the point the point is
not the point here is to get the
personal rest around that but even if
that doesn't happen the point is that
you've logged it with the authority and
you build that is the point right yeah
so once you don't do that you're
literally letting a rapist ghost cut
free to be able to other people and
because of you like if one guy is doing
it to all these girls eventually they
can build it yeah yeah if 10 girls have
the same story that don't know each
other but the problem so feminists will
say they're they're fighting for women
yet they don't go to the police to put a
rapists in jail I mean obviously some
people do but I think I think it is
really hard it is really hard for
somebody that has been in that situation
to actually speak out about it and maybe
I I think for a lot of cases that I've
seen it can be that sort of thing where
it's like one person comes out and then
it empowers someone else to come out and
then before you know it it's like 10
other people do as well I don't really
believe those girls either oh really no
how come how come they always turn to
come out when there's something to gain
though if they are so traumatized they
only ever come out when there is
something to gain yeah like I do I do
understand from that perspective but I
also think maybe as an individual it
could be really difficult to go up
against someone that say more powerful
has more status more money whatever but
then when kind of women come together I
think maybe they do feel more empowered
to be able to take that step of doing
the police interviews going through all
of that because it is traumatic to have
to do that
I can imagine it must be traumatic to
have to go through that I just think
genuinely if that happened to you you
would go to the police yeah I just have
a hard time because the truth is on your
side yeah go tell the truth and the
thing is I I really think police
are are I I don't think I I'm
I question the number that it's only one
or two percent because my my guys do
like my my gut my gut feeling is the way
they got that number was by just
surveying people and saying were you
graped and then and then putting that
against the number of yeah I don't know
I don't know I could be wrong I just
I've done this long enough so I know how
the feminists manipulate everything like
because the one you know the one in
three like women or one in four women
have been graped yeah that's wrong right
because they included like getting your
butt grabbed at a bar right oh right
like that's not the same thing like
that's happened to me before yeah that's
happened to me yeah it's just like okay
I still think that that's messed up
because I've seen it happen to a guy
okay yeah
but to even compare that to essay or
grape I think is insulting to real great
victims it's like all right that's not
on the same level it's still wrong
correct but you see how they're
manipulating that stat Yeah by including
things like that yeah or even taking off
a condom we're gonna put taking off a
condom at the same level of a woman
that's been graped or assaulted I think
that's insulting to real assault victims
I want every woman that's lied about
birth control to have the same energy
yeah I still think that that's up there
as well wrong but I think that do we
think that's grape I don't think most
feminine maybe you might but I don't
think most feminists would say you
graped that man I think if they're
trying to like baby trap a guy then 100
that's like so so what about some jail
should she go to jail yes thank you we
agreed
all right jail to him these often seem
very dangerous a level three mgtow
doesn't believe in dating women at all
and limits his interactions with women
as much as possible a level four mgtow
tries to limit his interactions with the
state and everyone else as much as
possible too he is what is referred to
as a guy that's ghosting or trying to
stay invisible to women and the state
all of this is explained in Greater
detail in a video marked number one
below in the description called mgtow
dating so once you know where you stand
with regards to the Spectrum then you
either have a choice to stay away from
women entirely or take varying
relationship risks then you basically
can start to gain true situational
awareness this is where you start to
identify different types of female
behavior and begin to understand what
motivates women to act in such ways one
very important thing to remember is that
many more women today in their 20s than
in past Generations are riding the [__]
Carousel this means they are having no
strings attached sex with in some cases
dozens of men before they decide to
settle down with a single guy if they
decide to settle down at all I'm linking
to my video called the [__] Carousel
which is number two down below from now
on each and every topic that I bring up
I will put a link to it below and at
this point I'm going to stop mentioning
it and let you explore these particular
topics on your own and explore the
description on your own as well
women look to settle down with a beta
male provider a blue pill man with
little to no understanding about female
nature if he's ignorant about the way
women operate then he's more easily
manipulated a man aware of how women
function in society and manipulate men
in covert ways are harder to guilt and
shame into doing the things that she
wants he knows the game so he's hard
have you ever seen a manipulative woman
yes okay what do they what do they act
like
I'm just laughing at [__] carousel
well I'll tell you I'll tell you you
know what percent of women are virgins
on our wedding nights like eight five
you know what it was a hundred years ago
like 80 85 I'm good you're good you're
good you're good so it kind of shows
because I used to I used to hear that
and I'd be like damn like we're not I'm
like I'm not doing that but then I
thought about in terms of a hundred
years ago yeah 95 of us would just be
thrown out yeah they'd be like we are
not dealing with these [__]
okay if we're gonna go off of a
historical point of view we're all
[__] yeah yeah
but so what do you what do you think men
should be like warned about how clinical
manipulative women yeah
um I yeah I guess like what we were
saying about a girl trying to like baby
trap them so wrong wow
um a girl that's trying to use them for
their money that's obviously really bad
as well
um but do you kind of mean like signs
that they're going to do that like
characteristics yeah that they might
have oh that's a difficult one have you
ever seen a woman date a guy but miss
her ex like you know oh yeah oh yeah
definitely yeah and that's terrible as
well like you should just be on your own
until you've healed from that situation
that's why I think it's so important for
women to have that time on their own
before they get into like a long-term
relationship or looking for marriage you
need to know yourself and what you want
and have actually healed yourself enough
to be a healthy partner yeah I think if
women typically actually healed yeah I
would agree but when women say healing I
found it's just like traveling partying
time for a whole face yeah it's never
like go to the gym yeah really like go
to a therapist that's sane
oh what's a male one then yes yes the
female therapists just make us crazier
yeah I mean why do you think I didn't
pursue my um me being a psychologist
after my degree probably a good idea I'm
already crazy
you know you actually don't seem to
[Laughter]
you'll be my new my new Protege yes
maybe we'll see we'll see how it goes
but what do you think men should be like
warned about when it comes to women
I guess that where a guy is probably
keeping his options open I feel like a
lot of women are doing the same now
um but I feel like that stems from
knowing that the guys have the options
as well so then you feel like maybe you
have to keep your options open too
um so yeah I guess they they should be
worried about a woman's loyalty okay I
think because I mean loyalty to me is
really important but I I have friends
that have like cheated on their
boyfriend of like five years for like a
prolonged period of time and where I you
know I think that that's so wrong I
think some of the people just don't see
that as wrong or they would do it
themselves or they would cheat on their
partner like I think loyalty is a big
thing that they should look out for
um and if a girl isn't loyal I think
even from the beginning then that's like
a big red flag too do you think most men
have options
no I think it's only like the top
percentile that do okay so we we agree
with that yeah yeah definitely it makes
a lot of sense when you find that out
yeah I was like oh that's why it's so
hard to like find a good guy
competing yes yes and I was like oh yeah
um
yes I think that most men are at a
disadvantage in relationships because
the women have like 10 options yeah and
the men have like maybe one I mean all
we have to do is post a bikini pic and
then you've got like 20 guys in your DMs
yeah and if you have a fight with your
boyfriend you can just go and choose one
of them yes yes she gets she kind of
gets not that I would ever do that but I
I mean we're not talking about you we'll
just talk about it in general yeah trick
into marriage protection and resource
extraction shame is the name of many
women's game and in this case it doesn't
work after a woman convinces her beta
male blue pill man that marriage is a
good idea for him then she has a child
or two which at some point allow her to
leave that relationship and use those
children as a way to get child support
from her husband
people wonder why men go their own way
and one of the biggest reasons is that
they have been burned by women through
the divorce courts and are often paying
lifetime alimony as well as child
support to their Ex-Wives in many cases
the family courts also award the full
value of the family home to wives
and the majority of men visiting this
YouTube channel are often in their 30s
40s and 50s men that have been taken to
the cleaner so to speak and have had
their eyes opened a little too late they
are here to become mgtows because they
are shocked at the way women took
advantage of them as well they're here
to understand how women use their beauty
and behavior to trick men
another important thing to remember is
that women age like milk while men age
like wine and I'm putting a link to a
video called women in the wall down
below many women's looks and ability to
attract a wealthy attractive mate
decline rapidly as they hit the age of
30. men's attractiveness often increases
with age because they tend to make more
money as they age and often have larger
bank accounts and savings while
generally women's earnings potential
Withers with their looks especially if
they've had children the age of 30 is
roughly where male and female values
intersect and then go in the opposite
direction
if a man doesn't get married by the age
of 35 or 40 then there's only roughly a
12 percent chance that he's going to get
married from that point forward another
reason men should go their own way is
because of [__] tests women often test
men's ability to be providers and
tolerate their horrible Behavior the
idea is to turn a man into an obedient
broken shell of his former self that
walks around saying yes dear all of the
time his Spirit has to be broken in many
cases so his resources become more
easily extracted and he is more
malleable he becomes silly putty in her
hands a woman asking a man to do
something over the top is not her being
loving or showing love but instead she's
testing him to see if he can be
manipulated and the ironic thing is that
women want to manipulate men but when
the manipulation Works they tend to lose
interest
do you think that's true
yes a hundred percent I feel like you're
awesome I like that you're honest yeah
like I do feel like you have to have
that masculine polarity they have to be
dominant they have to be in control
stoic otherwise you do lose attraction
100 and I can't I can't speak for all
women but for me I feel like I'm very
much in my feminine so I need that
masculine polarity do you think that
women constantly test men's masculinity
yes yeah definitely yeah it's not even
conscious I don't think no no I it's
like biological isn't it
yeah I don't know but you want to like
you want you want to be able to test
them to make sure that they're the best
option do you think that most men lead
relationships or most women lead
relationships like in general in general
yeah probably probably women most of the
time I'll tell you why I think that is
so if me and you let's just say we're
gonna sign a deal yeah okay and I get
paid to leave this deal yeah and you
lose everything you think your kids your
house your money
you're always going to be trying to make
me happy yeah so I think the government
the way they've set up marriage has
ruined relationships because it puts us
at such an advantage over men yeah that
unless he's the top guy and we feel like
we cannot replace him yeah we're paid to
leave and I think even a good woman on
her worst day yeah with the government
paying her to do something bad yeah
and all of these options is just going
to say
I'm not feeling it anymore yeah like I
honestly I never ever thought of it in
that way like I always thought of
marriage as like this magical thing like
being with husband my person forever and
I I just can't believe that I can't
believe that it is like by the
government in this way like it would
seem from what you're saying so this is
why I don't think mgtow is in self yeah
I think it's men that were shocked
because they married a chick they didn't
know she was in love with her ex like
you talked about right and they he got
the kids did everything for her yeah
just did everything to make her happy
she's never happy because that means
she's leading the relationship right
yeah and then he's completely shocked
because he never thought in a million
years she would ruin his maybe I'm a
mgtel because I'm shocked right now
hearing all of this yes yes yes and I'll
give you an example so one way the laws
they might not specifically say gender
yeah but the way that it's set up if a
man okay basically a lot of times in the
U.S I don't know if this part's the same
here but in the U.S the person that
spent the most time with the kids is
awarded custody right now on paper that
sounds right yeah however what if the
Man spent the most time with the kids
then would he still be awarded well they
say why aren't you providing for your
family like you're supposed to really so
yes well they actually say that yes yes
in court yes well that seems very unfair
and that's the problem men are so we
want men to protect and provide right
yeah yeah in divorce court they're
punished for it because if they do the
right thing and provide for their family
and they're spending less time with the
kids
and you see how it's like the men are
like what are we supposed to do but the
lawyers certainly will spin it in court
if he spent the most time with the kids
I mean come on like we're all gonna kind
of look at him like a loser a bit you
you would even even if it's not in law
yeah subconsciously you're wondering
well why didn't you work more so she
could stay right we're all thinking it
like let's just you know let's just be
honest so that's why I say feminist we
cannot be equal right because we will
always be below right but wait why does
that mean that we're below why does that
because we cannot do what men do we
cannot work the hours that men work we
cannot build these societies that men
build we can I just don't think we can
do what men do right okay we can offer
value in a different way yeah but the
only way we get to offer the most value
to society which I believe is being a
wife and a mother yeah would you agree
with that I yeah I would in in some
respects yeah so the only the only way
we can do that is if the men let us yeah
therefore and the only way we can build
a career is if the men let us build a
career everything we do we have to ask
the men to let us do we cannot be safe
in society without saying men please
keep us safe we cannot go to work
without saying men build these companies
so I can climb up the ladder yeah you're
saying so by this logic we cannot be
equal because everything we do we have
to say to the men can we do it therefore
they must be above us
it's okay take it take it in I I
couldn't the reason I came to this
conclusion was for months I couldn't
think of one thing that women did better
no because you asked you are so logical
like that is such a logical point it's
just it's just really hard for me to
wrap my head around because I've just
always thought you know that we are
equal so and that we do provide value in
different ways and you know even if that
maybe isn't the equal value or whatever
I still think that it is just as
important as each other yes I think that
women are absolutely important we
absolutely need women but the way we are
today I just don't think offers value as
a society I'm not saying I'm better than
anybody do you think it's maybe because
women haven't had the opportunity to do
those kind of jobs or whatever that the
men are doing that makes them be
superior do you think it's because they
don't get the same opportunities as men
no I think we've had plenty like to the
point that governments have grants to
get women in engineering yeah but then
how many women do you feel like are
comfortable going into like a male
dominance I actually think I think it's
really mean to push women into these
environments yeah I actually think
because the government's like you know
you'll walk past a construction site and
get cat called how many women are then
going to want to go and work on one no
that's actually not why I think it's
mean I think women come on if they
stopped cat calling us tomorrow we'd
kind of miss it
what if he was hot yeah
[Laughter]
have you Brad Pitt approached you like
that you would not I wouldn't care no
it's all based on if he's a trap you
know it is I feel like it's the way in
which they approach you like if a guy's
whistling at you like I'm not a dog
don't approach me like I mean if it's
Brad Pitt
but but okay I forgot where what we were
talking about before that it was got me
so yeah I've gone in a tundra
oh I think it's really mean that
feminists push women into these fields
and say you can do anything a man can do
do you know I think that's something
that always confused me about me being a
feminist because I feel like I've always
like my mum was a housewife and my dad
like has his business and worked so that
she could look after it she had a career
before but then she gave that up to look
after me and my brother which I am so
grateful for that I had you know my mum
around all the time that was amazing and
I've always wanted to do that you know
when I have children I would want to be
a housewife I love to cook and clean
like I feel like I don't think I'm a
traditional woman at all but I feel like
in some kind of sense
already I can hear it in your voice on
the show yeah I can hear it views about
marriage and things like that I guess is
it just me kicking like I can almost
hear when women have fathers and their
voices yeah
just by the way you guys like talk but
but I I think what feminists will do is
say hey young girls that are
impressionable right because you know
you could be convinced of anything else
oh definitely yeah so so you tell them
hey you can do anything a guy can do go
be an engineer here's a grant we're
really pushing women and then the women
go do it and they hate it yeah I just
feel like I wasn't made for that like
nine to five like hard working life
which I'll happily admit like maybe I'm
lazy I don't know I was just made to you
know have my own business and do my own
thing I'm a lot happier more comfortable
you know being at home with my dog and
doing that then I am going out to work
it gives me such bad anxiety it makes my
mental health terrible thank you for
that thank you for admitting yeah women
do not want to do a hard job I don't
either I do not want to do construction
none of that but I could never do that
correct and so like if we're talking to
the women and none of us want to do it
is it maybe it's not a patriarchy yeah
or an oppression it's just we don't want
to do it yeah but then there are some
women that do want to or maybe with
different societal conditioning would
maybe want to I don't think so I think
because there's a single one no have you
actually wanted to I I think there's
exceptions but usually those exceptions
are are like
they're very masculine women yeah
keyword you said with Society societal
conditioning yeah that is the problem
right okay that is the real problem
because women are being conditioned to
do things that are not they are not
beautiful right so yeah you shouldn't
condition women to to do things if you
were to leave men and women and not
interfere with them they would naturally
go and do the things just because that's
the problem is we're trying to tell
women be something you're not yeah and I
I think it's like kind of mean I'm like
why are they trying to do you think that
that's a big reason why so many women
struggle with their Mental Health
yeah I mean and I don't think we're
meant to have all these sexual partners
you know what I mean like I don't think
we're meant to have all these sexual
partners I don't think we're meant to
like
um go not have children you know like
that's what I realized one of the
biggest red pills for me was even though
I don't believe in feminism in a way
I've lived My Life as a feminist because
I went to college and it's even like you
being able to share your views now
people could argue that that's because
of feminism wrong no it's not no it's
not well you could we could the reason
the crazy thing is feminists
if feminism like feminists did not fight
to share their views because they were
openly able to share them right they
were not like prosecuted for being
feminists they were prosecuted because
they planned assassinations and they
were they were actually a very radical
group and the funny thing is they were
funded by a man right yeah so the the
that's that's the funny thing if you
follow the money it's a man usually
always but like this this idea that like
women couldn't like Cleopatra was in BC
yeah like Joan of Arc like there's
always been women in history that have
been influential we've always been able
to speak I would argue that most women
had more influence and power than most
men because we've always had Beauty yeah
and I mean Cleopatra she literally
seduced all the Roman emperors like yes
she was like running things yeah so she
also made the first ever vibrator as
well she was isn't that incredible I
know she put some bees in a jar and
that's how the first vibrator was ever
created
[Laughter]
but but
you you see even even that like that
it's not natural why do you have it's
like we're supposed to have husbands
yeah because like we've been you know
what I mean like with all her wisdom and
power she decided to invent the
vibration yeah yeah I think that was a
great decision from her no but what I'm
saying is think about it because we keep
trying to say men and women are the same
and I wanna equal so this is Cleopatra
who is literally one of the most
powerful maybe you could say one of one
of the smart smarter women that I've
lived but she chose to do something with
her brain that was still sexual if you
did a lot of things that were sexual
that's my point so why did why did she
use all that intelligence and influence
to actually do what demanded well she
did it all she did that as well
everything she did in the realm of men
was done by men not by her no but I feel
like she influenced them you know
because exactly they were in love with
her actually that you know people say
that she wasn't actually very beautiful
like people only fell for her because of
her intelligence and she could speak was
it like eight languages or something and
it was said that the man actually only
fell for her because of that and not for
her beauty she wasn't actually supposed
to be that bad
what Julius Caesar was a beta man of
course but but even even so it's like
women I would argue most women have had
power more power than men because we
start in the world young and beautiful
right yeah so I I would argue because
again most people didn't have power in
history it was such a small person yeah
of course I feel like because we learn
about that you assume that that's like a
huge amount yeah it was like the the
average jobs like in the U.S like two
three hundred years ago it was like coal
miner farmhand or
factory worker right yeah like what your
life sucks yeah it's like sucks sucks
sucks and then we'll point out and be
like men oppressed us and it's like men
built the whole system like we couldn't
even have a society to oppress if we
didn't have met right so it's like if
the women could build a society that go
do it but we can't but do you feel like
that's maybe because like men were in
the army they had more like strength in
that kind of way and like the physical I
think I think men are built Superior to
women just like physically I think
there's a couple things one they so when
me and you have a conversation we go we
a lot of times you'll say it depends
yeah and your default is more
subjectivity yeah whereas they use like
Logic No they they do hierarchy so Matt
you're not gonna notice it I don't even
notice it but men like size each other
up yeah and like there's an underlying
threat of violence right and they
organize themselves into hierarchy where
women it's more that we might do social
hierarchy but when it comes to like like
we we just we we trend more towards
subjectivity it's subjective I don't
want to call a ho a hoe yeah where the
men went in and they said this is a hoe
this is a [__] this is right when we did
the show right so so the the men are
superior when it comes to building and
running societies and the fact that they
can make a hierarchical organization to
make a society run yeah women just don't
do that yeah I guess we get our periods
one to end we're just crazy naturally we
can't how are you know women before our
period we definitely women are more
likely to wage war yeah because it will
get our period and be like I'm fighting
with Brazil [__] up and then also we
don't have to fight in the world yes yes
yes so a lot of people think like I hate
women but I actually think what they've
done to us the last hundred years has
been mean yeah because we're all
confused none of us know how to have a
happy stable relationship like I just
think it's like we're all just confused
yeah and we've been told for a hundred I
was even thinking like I did Sports from
the time I was like
ten you know that raises your
testosterone oh I did gymnastics and
dancing yes so a lot of times like women
in sports will be more masculine what
kind of sport did you do I did
basketball volleyball oh I can see that
you know I loved volleyball yeah I never
like did it like at school or anything
but I loved playing it and you know all
the lesbians are on the basketball team
yeah because it's a more masculine right
yeah but so it's like they're confusing
us yeah they're confusing us and they're
telling us to do things we're not so do
you think that girls shouldn't do Sports
well I don't wanna I love sports so much
that's really hard for me I don't think
surely it's not a bad thing for girls to
do Sports ah I don't know there's there
it's tough because I look at data and I
do see what sports does to women in the
long term and I see like a lot of the
women that take volleyball to the
extreme basketball to the extreme they
end up by them damn selves right so yeah
maybe if that is that what's right for
that kind of Interest well I I do
believe in Free Will and free choice but
what I don't think we should to do is
push women to do things that they're not
naturally they don't naturally want to
do yeah I think maybe I just naturally
want to be an athlete my parent it was
just a family thing but like I don't
think we should be in society pushing
women and having all these programs to
push us to be Engineers push us to be
does that make sense yeah I guess it's
kind of like you know when parents push
their kid to do it correct if they want
to do it so be it yeah because I mean I
love gymnastics I was so naturally good
at it like yeah I guess I would have
hated it if my like parents that's what
they're doing in the schools and society
and with the money it's so funny men pay
like seven I we I calculated it out the
other day King like I took the actual
numbers it's like 72 or 74 of taxes so
they take their money to push women into
their fields right is that crazy they'll
put grants it's like they'll take care
we'll take the men's money and and pay
the women to take their jobs
I mean it's it's really hard for me
because I feel like it just depends on
the individual I feel like there are
some women that are maybe at the more
masculine end of this correct scale that
you're right thrive in that kind of
environment right and I say have them do
it but have them do it like naturally
right yes not without pushing them into
it yes and that's what I can get on
board with that and that's what I think
I think the feminists that are trying to
make it equal in like engineering and
all these fields I think that's a mean
and I think I think it harms the women
because we spend all this money and then
we find out we don't even like this
stuff yeah oh no just gonna be a
stay-at-home mum now no but I think it's
still good for there to be like equal
access to the opportunities so you know
not necessarily pushing people into it
or like forcing them in with money or
like any kind of incentive but I think
it would still be nice for there to be
like equal opportunity to do those
things if they want to there is
but do you think a woman feels
comfortable going into like a concert
how does her feeling comfortable have
anything to do with there being equal
access because I feel like surely if
they if they don't feel comfortable to
go into it then they can't necessarily
I'll tell you I'll tell you a lot of men
don't feel comfortable going to the gym
a lot of men don't feel comfortable I
don't think anyone feels confident
exactly so that's no problem it has
nothing to do with reality I think if
they're going to face like gender-based
violence or like harassment or anything
to do with that then that could be maybe
an issue that's crazy that's as the
argument like if they are going to face
they might feel like they're more likely
to face like gender-based harassment
though like I'm walking into like a
construction no problems but I mean if
you've been cat called on the
construction site the day before and
then you're you're walking into a
construction classroom with the same
kind of people are you going to feel
comfortable doing that as a woman
you're conflicting two different things
because first of all you're saying if
you've been cat called so it doesn't
mean that the the construction site was
cut called on is the site she's going to
work on no but you might you might then
kind of I guess if something like that
happens to you you might then kind of
view it through have you ever have you
ever been in um in like a situation
where like have you ever been on like a
job site of a construction like not
working not just like walking by like
actually interacting with them no no so
so I used to sell Plumbing Tech yeah
okay so I used to sell like parts to
Plumbers basically like the pipe Hangers
On plump yeah just very unique but
whatever
yeah and so what we would do is we would
go to the schools and we would teach
them how to use our product so it was me
and a room full of men and we were like
here you go and
what I couldn't believe was going to
these they're like training centers was
how mean men are to each other when
we're not around right yeah they bully
each other they make fun of each other
they harass each other but men don't
whine right so what women do is they
expect to go in the men's space and not
get harassed bullied yeah but you feel
like they're just treating them equally
in the same way that they're just in the
man right that's really interesting and
so what happens is women say let me into
the man's world yeah and then the men
say okay come into our world and they
say no no not like that you can't do
that this is all wrong and then my thing
is if you're gonna go into a man's world
like that would be like me being in the
red pill space yeah and saying I don't
like the way the men are talking then
get out but then I'm kind of my point
was you know if it's gender-based
harassment so if it's like groping or
anything like that do you feel like
that's kind of a different story too if
they're just like you know having a joke
well one my first question is do men get
gender-based harassment yes so men get
bullied much harder by other men than
they would ever do to a woman yes I
think a woman in a male workplace is
going to get way more favors yeah and
also is that because it's full like
sexual gain from their boss or whatever
well I think all men will let sleep with
you if you let them yeah pretty much
yeah just yeah you know if you're half
attractive anyway
um I don't think men should be grabbing
you at work yeah so we could do a no
touching the women policy but a lot of
times women will be flirting with the
men right they'll have their boobs out
like half the time these chicks are
dressed like hookers right and then
they're like well why did the men grab
my well I mean it's kind of confusing to
the I know nowadays like the ass
grabbing is like taboo the men don't
even do it anymore but like 10 15 years
ago that used to be like you know like
people just kind of like did that yeah
the environment's changed yeah and so
the women will be half naked yeah boobs
out and then be like why are they
deserve to like have that kind of well
I'm saying it's mixed signals because
you're signaling to the guy flirt with
me hit on me and then say Oh but don't
do it so do you feel like they're kind
of asking for it in a way because of the
way that they're dressed I I would say
they're signaling that they want it I
would not say they're asking for it I
would say they're signaling like if I go
out I I dress a different way when I go
to work than if I go out yeah you know
and so and it I think one sends the
signal of professionalism one sense that
you're going out to talk you know yeah
but then I think most women don't go to
the office like with their boobs out
like most people do wear like
professional dress in the workplace
surely really is that like isn't that
rules on that like skirt has to be like
below the knee I don't know I've never
worked in an office
what happens when they say they give
those dress codes do the women say
that's so reasonable or do they cry
sexism well if it was equal for men and
women if the dress code was like an
equal one will they say it's reasonable
if it was equal then yeah
how can the dress could be equal when we
don't wear the same things well just as
in like you know if they're saying that
women have to wear a skirt for example
and can't wear trousers but like if a
woman wants to wear trousers then she
should be able to okay so my you know
what's funny my high school we had pants
yeah and everybody had pants I went to
Catholic school so we had uniforms oh
nice and the issue was in the other high
schools and the reason they did that was
because before they had skirts and the
girls would roll them up yeah come on
you all did it at school yeah you can't
make this [__] up yeah you know women
won't follow the dress code anyway yeah
that's cool yeah that's cool it's a
professional environment right right
yeah exactly like people don't hook up
in the workplace you know what I mean
it's like so they roll the skirts up and
then the teachers say hey you got to
roll them down and how many times we get
videos on social media of the girls
saying oh this is sexist you're right
okay well you wanted to be in a man's
world yeah and then they say okay we
don't want the attention from men we
don't want to be harassed so they say
okay let's protect you from that here
are some dress codes and they say well I
don't want the dress codes I want my ass
out but then I feel like the dress code
doesn't even protect you from that the
amount of times I've been like shouted
out in the street cat cold when I'm
literally wearing no makeup and sweats
like I wear no makeup on a daily basis
and that's like when I get cat cold the
most sometimes I feel like it doesn't
even they don't even pay like take into
consideration what you're wearing well
just wait 10 years you know you're still
25 you know what I mean
a bit of the argument because reality is
how many we said it's like men are
really going to their workplace to try
and jeopardize their where they are
getting their bread from the reality is
even if anyone is going to sexually
harass you at work
it's going to be someone that deserves
to get what they're going to get but the
reality is a lot of women go to work and
make the workplace not conducive for
most men not for abusers they make the
workplace non-conducive for most men by
coming with all these complaints this
um attitude and all of that and then
they also still at the same time want to
be able to dress however they want so
it's like okay you don't want the rules
you want to be able to Signal give off
all these sexual signals at work but
then you also want to complain when
the men reciprocate and respond to your
signals so it's kind of like you can't
eat your cake have you ever have you
ever had a work Crush
um yeah definitely have you ever flirted
with a guy at work yes were you
harassing him no because I feel like it
was Mutual but but I feel like you see
so the man could feel like it wasn't
making mutual yeah well it was somebody
that I I did end up dating but this is
the we're in a privileged position
because most men if you open up the door
they're gonna they're gonna take it you
know what I mean yeah but then it's not
the same so and a lot of times have you
ever flirted for attention yes every
group right so for attention all the
time do you see how this is confusing to
the guys because we'll we'll we'll go in
these outfits that are saying that
signal to them flirt with me yeah we'll
flirt with them and then if if they're
not attractive enough we're like wait
not you I I don't know I feel like I
just like to make people feel good so
I'll flirt with like even if he's not
like that good looking I'll still want
to like play with him and just be
charming and be kind I don't think it
has to like mean anything you see that's
a problem because when you do that the
first day and then the second day maybe
you're not in the mood and then he tries
to float you because he just felt like
okay she did it the first day so she
might be on to me yeah but then he tries
it the next day and then you're not in a
great mood and then you're gonna report
him to HR no I would know no not at work
I wouldn't do this at work what I'm
saying is like in general this is what
would happen right the reality come on
you've never like
I'll before I date a guy I'll change my
mind like 10 times yeah but yes no yes
no yes so it's just we're confusing
people so we go into these men's World
and are like
we need to change it to accommodate us
and I say if you want to be in a man's
world be in it yeah don't don't change
it just be in it right that's a fair
point that's a fair point
with regards to love there are often
questions as to whether women are even
capable of loving men the way that men
love women men scale mountains because
they love women they cross Seas invent
things write poetry and revolutionize
the world it's my own opinion as well as
the opinion of many other mgtows that
women are not hardwired for the same
level of love that men are this is
partially to do with the fact that women
need to look after children and need to
divert those resources elsewhere anyways
mgtow men want North America and Europe
to turn into Japan we want men refusing
to provide love and resources to women
on a civilization-wide scale until
Society crumbles
women are selfish yet men are told to
man up and take responsibility and we
don't want to take responsibility for
childlike women that have given up on
their own responsibilities but continue
to demand that we men provide them
entitlements because they have a golden
vagina
when a man tries to live for himself
women call it a midlife crisis and try
to shame him back into submission yet
when a woman goes through menopause men
are supposed to just tolerate her hot
flashes as well as mood swings but a man
in a midlife crisis needs therapy
according to women
the guy we mgtows look up to the most is
Nikola Tesla a lifelong bachelor that
invented many of the technologies that
we use today he registered hundreds of
patents and invented the 20th century by
many accounts
do you think that he could have invented
all the things that he did if he had a
wife and children to support most mgtows
also avoid long-term relationships
because women have multiple male friends
that they use for different functions
effectively women have the equivalent of
a male harem one man to sleep with one
to bankroll her another one to use is an
emotional tampon and other men for all
kinds of functions One Man simply can't
satisfy the Modern Woman and the sooner
men realize this the sooner they can go
their own way a traditional marriage and
family is a great risk for men in this
day and age if a man wants a child of
his own I would suggest that he go to
either Mexico or Thailand and have a
surrogate mother give birth to his own
child that way his child can never be
taken away by the mother and he often
pays 30 to 40 thousand dollars to have
his own child free and clear that he can
raise and any which way he wants
what's also really unfortunate today is
that many men get married and now that
they're married just now do they realize
they've gotten married and have kids and
are effectively mgtows they see the
benefit to it but they're stuck in the
relationship this issue of being a
closeted mgtow is one that many of my
listeners face other men get married
because they like to play a game called
Captain Save A Hoe they want to rescue
women by paying off their student loans
buying them a nice home and Furnishing
it as well as spoiling them rotten like
princesses yet many of the women they
tend to rescue are used up [__] that
have been riding the [__] Carousel for
most of their lives and many women
prefer to date bad boys and jerks
instead of good loving supportive and
good-hearted men many men can't even get
dates or relationships these days
because they seem to be unattractive to
women and women have no interest in
dating them and having sex with them but
it's much harder for unattractive men
than it is for unattractive women and
men that are incapable of getting dates
and getting into relationships are often
called tfellers or true Force loneliness
type of guys
many of them are bitter because they
cannot get female attention and many of
them focus on conspiracies theories
instead as a hobby some men go overseas
and look for foreign Brides to marry and
this too is a bad idea because female
nature is the same everywhere around the
world bringing a foreign bride back to a
Western Country ensures that in many
cases that she will leave you many times
foreign women are marrying foreign men
just to get a new passport and once they
enter this new country they find more
attractive males if she left the country
of her own origin behind what makes you
think that she won't leave you behind
of like thinking it's just so
it's like it kind of scares me in a way
that men like really believe this and
really think this way I do find it quite
terrifying what part was terrifying
I guess that they just view women in
this negative way that we're all like
manipulative and that we're not capable
of loving a man in the same way that
they are a verse actually I think that's
true I think we don't love the same
maybe not the same but do you think that
we love as deeply as they do
um I've actually thought a bit about
this
I think men will love you through thick
and thin more than women so I think
um because women his I I think it's just
we're hardwired into our DNA we needed a
guy that protected and provided for us
otherwise we would die
so if we if we have any signals that a
guy isn't going to do that we're going
if a guy if we see our guy get beat up
by another guy we're trying to go if we
see our guys not making money like he
used to be we're trying to go I don't
think it makes us bad people I think we
had to ensure that our DNA got passed on
and I I understand that from the
biological perspective but then do you
not think that it's a little bit
reductionist because you know we have
our own minds we have cognitive
processes we have social conditioning so
well so I think that women are very
emotional yeah and I think when a woman
is in love I think I think when a woman
is in love she does love harder than a
man like that's what I think you'll see
you'll see a woman go like Bonnie and
Clyde leave everything she knows
whatever however
feelings change and I think women men
love harder because that feeling of
being like crazy in love will only last
so long but you think for men it lasts
longer I I think men just love
differently like I think like
uh like a woman when she's done with a
guy she's done yeah or a man I think men
like kind of love I don't want to say
every girl they've been with but I think
men they release a hormone when they
have sex with us so they're they're
territorial over like women that they've
been with like I there was um this guy
that taught men how to get laid he'd
slept with like thousands or I don't
know hundreds I saw him in a weekend it
was like um a pickup boot camp they
literally teach men how to get laid it's
very it's great and this guy I saw him
take home like four different chicks in
a weekend and he told me that he still
gets me like that he would always have
sex with a girl and like the next person
like she would marry right yeah and he
he would tell me that he would still
feel some type of way when they got
married very I I find that so
unbelievable because I feel like as
women you would think we get more
emotionally I think we'll I think we can
only love one guy at a time and
sometimes it's not the guy we're with
do you think that's what we talked about
earlier I feel like it's common for
women to hyper fixate on one person I
think that me and a lot of my friends
will hyper fix it on one person to kind
of avoid maybe our own pain or what
we're going through a hyper fixate on a
guy yeah I think I think that guy was
just the best you could do and you
couldn't replace him he had something if
you saw like some of the guys that my
friends like hyper fixing it doesn't
have to be it doesn't have to be looks
yeah it doesn't like it there's
something about him that she could not
easily replace otherwise she would not
be fixated on him yeah I get that I do
get that but then do you think when they
find someone new then they hyper fixate
on on the new guy if if he's better if
he's better yeah which a lot of times
women cannot do better because we age
yeah right and so we have less market
value because I do see that I think when
I've been you know head over heels in
love with someone and like hyper fixated
on them and found it really really
difficult to get over them it has taken
I guess someone new to come in for me to
be able to move on from that and I feel
like it's the same kind of feelings and
the same kind of situation and Hyper
fixation but just with a different face
every time and that's made me realize
that okay I need to do the series in a
work now to heal from that so and then
my question is what percent of women
actually end up with the man they want
if we're all going for 20 of men that
means most of us don't end up with the
guy we want so what do we do so there's
no other choice right I'm not even
saying it's a bad thing like I think
it's better right to get married but but
the the issue we're going to get into is
like that's why I think in general men
love harder than women because if we
take a hundred marriages I think the men
tend to love the women more because one
the women leave more yeah so that that
says something right oh really yeah and
and two I I think there's more men that
are head over heels in love with their
wife than there are women that are head
over heels in love with their men
because you see men do a lot more for
women than women typically do for men
today right right so do you do you not
think that they do kind of different
jobs so even in like a traditional I do
think but let's let's take traditional
right yeah what percent of women like
are and I I don't have this either so
I'm not saying like I'm just analyzing
the market yeah most men make more than
the women yet most women are fatter than
the men right so what does that have to
do with it though that's that's what
starts with right money and looks right
like if we bare I mean I'm not saying
women want looks too but most men are
taller than the women yeah but most
women you know it's more common for a
girl to not be able to cook than to
really know how to cook
I I I don't know I feel like me and all
my friends like we love to cook we'll
always do like meals for each of them my
experiences that I know a lot of women
that are really good I I would say when
you look at women in general I would say
we know less about cooking than women 50
years ago do you think I I don't know I
feel like for me it was definitely
passed down from my grandma do you do
not feel the same like you no I think
because women had working moms mostly
you were very lucky you got to stay home
yeah maybe I was right right into that
yeah but now we have one out of three
kids are born out of well I actually
think it almost hit I think it just hit
50 of kids are born out of wedlock wow
so where are they going to learn it from
if their mom's at work yeah you only
have so much time in a day you can't do
everything no that is true
um because yeah where are they gonna
learn I feel like as well though you do
learn when you like go off to University
or and you have to start like cooking
for yourself or when you live alone then
surely you have to learn to cook like
surely if you're living on your own
which most people do I'm assuming when
they get to like a lot of takeouts
that's what happens oh yeah we got we
get delivery I mean we're all guilty of
that but surely you cook for yourself
sometimes if you're working like say a
normal job on a normal wage you can't be
getting delivery like every single night
you'd be surprised no you can't well
like a normal salary like
women women also own the majority of the
debt right so we also like spend more no
no no credit cards yes we do another
possible solution for men looking for
love are synthetic lovers in Japan
people pay for affection conversation
sex and often each of their needs are
met in a service type of setting so what
did you think of mgtow
the voice that they do for it is really
weird it's kind of funny yeah I love the
[__] Carousel that was my favorite if
I'm gonna take anything away from this
it's that
yeah you know I that one when I first
heard it I was like well that's not nice
but then I started looking at the stats
right I was like this doesn't there's
women that have admitted there was a
survey of women in college yeah in
college yeah girls said they had slept
with seven guys a year that was the
average how do they have the time I said
the same but I'm like if I'm looking at
these numbers it's not good for us I'm
like this isn't I mean go them slay
um
no don't slay no no no no no
why don't you tell the people where they
can find you oh so on Instagram it's
Layla Lazelle on Tick Tock it's Layla
underscore Lazelle and on YouTube Just
Layla nazelle Layla nasal everywhere all
right guys go subscribe to her I'm gonna
I'm gonna bring you back you were you
were good conversation thank you I
appreciate it thank you so much for
having me on thank you I learned a lot
man
um like the video guys on your way out
subscribe to the channel and let me know
in the comments what should I tell her
next I was thinking maybe Peterson Ben
Shapiro I don't know what but let me
know in the comments like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
I'll talk to you next time